well more than 2.6 million people are
now thought to have fled ukraine and as
you would expect the nearest countries
have accepted the most refugees more
than a million have arrived in poland
alone in comparison the united kingdom
has accepted
1305 that's according to figures
published on thursday
but is that about to change with a new
scheme offering 350 pounds a month to
anyone who provides a room for a
ukrainian refugee well we'll find out
we're joined now by the leveling up
secretary michael gove to explain more
thank you very much for being with us
good morning i'm keen to get to the
latest scheme uh in just a moment but
first is there an update you can give to
us on what the latest military situation
is in ukraine well the situation in
ukraine is perilous
it's uniquely challenging for the
ukrainian people and for their armed
forces um they've shown amazing bravery
and courage over the course of this
conflict but of course we know that
vladimir putin
is prepared to escalate there are
several grisly options that he has
at his disposal and that's why it's so
important that we continue to provide
all the support that we can uh to
president zielinski and to his team what
are those grizzly options then well
again we know that um from what vladimir
putin has done elsewhere from what he's
done in syria and what he has done in
chechnya that he is capable of
devastation on a terrible terrible scale
um and that is why
we need to demonstrate solidarity with
the ukrainian people um and also that's
why the the military support the lethal
aid the united kingdom has been
providing threat and that other
nato allies have been providing
throughout is so important but again we
can't second-guess the decisions of the
ukrainian armed forces about chemical
weapons and the prime minister telling
my colleague beth ricky this week that
that's something that he fears well
again i i don't want to um get into the
weeds and the detail of not really
wheezing details talking about the
reality of a chemical weapons attack
well quite uh what we know is that um uh
putin's calculation
uh that he would be able to uh
relatively quickly capture the the heart
of ukraine
that calculation has proven to be
unfounded we know that he is capable of
terrible terrible uh violence
but again
i am not a military expert and i would
not want uh your viewers to think that
i'm the right person to get into a
detailed discussion of uh chemical or
other warfare all i can do is to is is
to share with you
uh what um uh uh those of us in
government who are wrestling with this
no which is a uh that putin's
miscalculated b in the past he has shown
a level of ruthlessness beyond that
which um any other leader on earth is
capable of at the moment and c what
happened in grazing what happened in
aleppo these are terrifying portents um
obviously i understand you're not a
chemical weapons expert but if chemical
weapons
are used that's a war crime how do we
respond is that the time when we step up
our actions when it comes to the war in
ukraine well i think it's already you're
absolutely right it would be a war crime
um it was a war crime um uh in syria it
is the case that um already vladimir
putin has committed war crimes already
so if he crosses the red line and uses
chemical weapons what is our response
well again uh our response uh is
something that will be agreed in concert
with our allies and it's not for me at
this stage i can completely understand
your desire for for clarity but it's not
for me to spell out in advance of um
nato and uh
our allies being clear about what
they're saying what's the uk
government's position you won this
program as a representative by the uk
government what is the position on what
the uk response would be
if putin uses chemical weapons well it
would be a response specifically
targeted to deal with that escalation
but i'm not going to spell out myself
what that response is because it's for
the prime minister in concert with our
allies to deal with the situation which
none of us would want to see um okay um
understood um is there a concern
about an escalation we'll be hearing
from uh uh mr volkov later and an ally
of alexander who says that he believes
putin is crazy enough to use nuclear
weapons is that a real concern for the
uk government yes i think well i think
uh there are different um ways in which
you can describe how vladimir putin is
operating um i think he's operating
according to a set of criteria totally
detached from those which you or i would
consider to be reasonable or rational
but
by his own lights what he's doing is
pursuing a conflict which he believes he
has to win we have to make sure that he
loses there are people who are um
even now calibrating what our response
should be to that the defense security
and intelligence experts in our own
country and elsewhere but yes i don't
think it's uh
helpful to think of putin as
mad
i think what we do need to uh think of
him as and we do need to recognize is
someone whose ruthlessness takes them
into a moral
sphere that the rest of us would find
almost impossible to conceive of and
that moral sphere could include the use
of nuclear weapons in your view well
again it's not for me to get into some
of the the detailed judgments about uh
uh uh the correct military response
because again uh really detail is this
is a huge um you know and very clear
question is that a real concern for the
uk government well
russia is a nuclear-armed power um it's
military dropped and um uh it clearly
has a
uh
a set of steps by which they can move to
that we're in perilous uh territory but
by definition
when you're talking about weapons of
such horrific potential and when you're
talking about strategy and diplomacy of
such delicacy then someone like me
shouldn't intrude into these
calculations this is a matter for heads
of government and for those with direct
military experience
and that's why i hope you'll excuse my
caution when we're dealing with such
momentous and potentially terrifying
escalation okay um
would you we're going to remove on to uh
refugees in the scheme you're announcing
now and do you have an update on the
number of refugees from ukraine that the
uk has accepted yes we've had um more
than 300 000 visas that have been issued
um and of course it's important to
recognize that from tuesday i'm talking
about the family scheme um from tuesday
it will be the case that uh
the majority people will no longer need
to apply for visas at visa application
centers we'll accept ukrainian passports
people will be able to come into this
country and as well as the number of
people who are coming in through the
family scheme which is rapidly expanded
as you mentioned right at the beginning
of the program there's a new homes for
ukraine scheme which also has no cap to
the number of people who can come here
so just to clarify 300 000 visas that's
up from 1 305 on thursday
3 000 more than 3 000 views more than 3
000 right i was going to say that is
quite
very
an
escalation otherwise um just explain
what your new idea is to try and help
refugees come to the uk well we want to
make sure that every available bed
that
we have in this country that can be made
available every available home that can
be made available to those who are
fleeing persecution is mobilized um we
know that there are a large number of
people in this country generous hearted
and in a position to provide homes and
businesses and to charities as well so
what we're doing is saying we the
government will act in solidarity and in
cooperation with you we will provide not
just a a payment um but we will also
make sure that people who come here have
the chance to work and get the support
from the nhs from education and from
other services that they need um so the
idea is that you register an interest
yes tomorrow monday are you going to be
registering an interest yourself well
i'm exploring what i can do yes and and
i think there'll be lots of people i i
understand the leader of the labour
party as well yeah are looking to see
what they can do and so you will be
signing up to try and offer a room well
again i'm going to make sure that i do
everything i can as an individual to
support um and again each individual
will have their own circumstances it is
the case that something like
one in 10 uk citizens which is an
amazing amount have said that they they
want to do something to help but we want
to make sure that people are in a
position to help because inevitably it's
a significant commitment and i recognize
that
we need to operate in uh in different
ways and in different phases to help
people who are fleeing persecution so
are you offering a room i was a bit i'm
still not completely clear well i'm in
the process of seeking to see what i can
do yes and i again uh you know as with
so many things um i think that there are
individuals whose own family
circumstances mean that they can or
can't move as quickly as they'd like um
right let's talk numbers you say it's
uncapped but you must have done some
modeling what's your estimate for the
number of people who could come to the
uk through this scheme um tens of
thousands tens of thousands you think is
that enough if you look at the
numbers for example of ukrainian
refugees poland taking in 1.5
million france say they're expecting 50
to 100 000 in the coming weeks germany
over 80 000 by wednesday it still feels
you know tens of thousands it's
relatively no numbers if you look at the
level of the crisis yes and the number
of
children
elderly extremely vulnerable refugees is
that really enough well there are so
many things that we have to do um and
again you know in a way in a face of
crisis of this magnitude we have to make
sure that we do what we can when we can
um and that's why our approach is phased
it's also why it's um alongside the
humanitarian support that we're giving
so earlier this week leaders from four
of the countries closest to ukraine um
were meeting with the prime minister and
they were grateful to britain for
providing what's needed most now which
is humanitarian aid to those countries
on the front line who've taken such a as
you quite rightly point out huge influx
of individuals
once we do everything we can in order to
provide that humanitarian support
expertise uh boots on the ground money
uh alongside that we can then see how
many people we can take to the uk and
again
many of the people who are there um will
want to at the moment stay
close to ukraine it is the case that for
family and other reasons there'll be
many people who will want to stay in
poland slovakia um or romania but of
course there are many others whom we can
accommodate here who can come here and
to whom we wish to give a warm welcome i
want to talk a little bit about the
support that these people will need when
they come here obviously having money
that you're giving to us the sponsors of
the families and but it feels like a
very different profile of refugee to
ones that we've seen before you know
there's a lot of children yes a lot of
elderly a lot of people who will need
access to public services that you say
the government is willing to provide so
does that mean that you're looking at
giving more money to schools for example
who will be accepting ukrainian children
yes there'll be money available for
local authorities money available for
much um for each uh individual who comes
will be just over ten thousand pounds
per individual available to local
authorities then there's so per per
individual ukrainian you're just willing
to fund up to ten thousand pounds in
service just over actually yes to to
each local government area um and then
there'll be additional payments for
those children who are off school age
and who need to be accommodated within
the educational system
everyone will have access to uh full nhs
care including mental health the ten
thousand pounds that's to each local
authority area per individual per
individual right okay thank you and
that's um useful and another thing that
i have some questions about is the fact
that you need to name a ukrainian in
order to accept them into your house
i mean
that's going to severely restrict
numbers isn't it if you're a sky news
viewer for example you've got a spare
room you're desperate to do something to
help after you've seen the appalling
images from kiev and elsewhere
you don't know someone from ukraine do
you no but
you you may do but
firstly the alternative to that would be
government attempting to match uh people
in ukraine to uh individuals here um and
uh that could be quite a slow
bureaucratic process um we know that
there are charities and we're working
with them that are helping to identify
people on the ground and helping to
identify people here to create that
matching process so rather than it being
simply government on its own we want to
make sure that uh the the web of
individual connections um and the the
good heartedness of those who are
supporting charities can help here so we
know that for example there will be
churches and faith groups that we know
that there will be jewish groups we know
that there will be uh groups like
stonewall and others that will be doing
everything they can to identify
individuals who can benefit and
individuals who want to help is there a
concern that people could effectively
match up with people on social media so
you see someone on instagram or twitter
and you could try and
inform links that way yes and part of
the idea yes and is there safeguarding
concerns over that that you can
effectively
choose if you like a vulnerable refugee
that you may have seen on instagram or
twitter to come into your personal home
well one of the reasons why we um uh are
operating the system in the way that we
are is precisely for that reason we
absolutely do need to make sure first of
all that the people um in ukraine are
who they they say they are so there
needs to be some security checks there
um there's
been understandable concern about this
scheme being exploited possibly by by
criminal elements um so that's the first
thing then the second thing is we do
need to make sure that people here are
who you know are are in a position
um to provide that support which is why
there will need to be security checks as
well to make sure that
those
i think it would only ever be a tiny
minority but still those who might be
intent on exploitation uh can be
prevented from uh abusing this system
and how quickly is all this going to
happen when could we expect to see the
first refugees entering the uk under the
district people can register their
interest on um monday uh matching will
be taking place from friday um i would
expect that in a week's time we'll see
the first people coming here under the
scheme now
honestly has there been a bit of
disagreement in government over this
because if there's been reports of
number 10 blocking home office schemes
it feels as if there's been is taking
quite a long time to get to this point
has there been any disagreement behind
the scenes about the best way to proceed
you know what there's been is a very
focused determined effort to
get a scheme that uh that works and
meets the need of the hour so
um
you know people who are close politics
watchers will have seen and know that
i've been working very closely with the
home secretary throughout in order to
make sure that this scheme can work um
and it requires all of government so uh
it is the home office quite rightly that
is responsible for our security for
making sure the areas that we've just
mentioned that the people coming here
are the right people that the people
presenting are the right people you can
look at me in the eye and say you've got
full confidence the home office to
deliver the schemes yeah totally okay a
couple more questions before we end um
how hopeful are you that the talks
between russia and ukraine could end in
a resolution is there any compromise
deal that you can see been struck i pray
that we can have peace but it's
difficult to see what a compromise deal
would look like okay
and there's questions in the sunday
times uh about uh afghani lebedev this
is the newspaper owner yes uh son of a
former kbg kgb
agent given a peerage by boris johnson
that the security uh services raised
questions about and it's also come out
that um back in 2013 the head of mi6
refused to meet him if this is a man and
he obviously denies any security but if
this is a man who the security services
have repeatedly raised concerns about is
the prime minister behaved a bit
foolishly to say the least here no i
don't think so um uh i've met um lord
lebedev as the prime minister has um at
no point did anyone ever say to me that
it would be inappropriate uh to meet him
and to um to talk to him and i think
none of those concerns are passed on
even though in 2013
the sunday times believes that they were
passed on to people at least around
boris johnson nobody has ever said to me
and um uh uh i've met mr mr lord levita
as you know is in public um and nobody
has ever suggested to me that that was
wrong there's something else as well i'd
want to say so you're happy to call him
lord lebedev then yes well
one of the other things i should say is
that
um uh lord labidev has been clear
through the pages of the evening
standard the newspaper of which he is
proprietor that he wholeheartedly
disapproves of this conflict he's been
critical of vladimir putin's actions i
think one of the things that vladimir
putin would like us to do is to
have a
an approach in the uk where we said that
everyone of russian ancestry um was
somehow
you know
is somebody who the security services
have intervened over the periods the
head of msx refused to meet oh quite and
it's not just some
like normal russian person who lives on
your street
no uh but it's also the case that again
um i think it's um appropriate to
recognize that what um uh putin wants to
do is is to
divide us in this way
again
the sunday times are reporting things
today
they're news to me um but of course i
take account fully of the integrity of
their reporting okay just finally and
the prime minister expected to travel to
saudi arabia next week for talking about
oil trying to move the uk away from
dependence on russia from russian energy
now of course this comes as saudi arabia
announces the execution of 81 men one of
the biggest mass executions for decades
are you comfortable with the uk relying
on oil from saudi arabia
well we have to rely on oil from a
number of countries
many of whose human records human rights
records we wouldn't um um
in fact we don't approve of um every
time a uk government minister is in
saudi arabia we raise human rights
concerns alongside the other work that
we do i guess we arm the prize sell arms
to saudi arabia what's a little oil
well again saudi arabia is a security
partner of the united kingdom um i think
that there are human rights concerns
we're clear about those
but we also recognize that uh at a time
when the world is in a fragile situation
uh that uh diplomacy alongside um uh
clarity on human rights is important
okay thank you very much for being on
the programme uh today michael thank you
thank you